[Musik]
willst du mich verarschen
und
[Musik]
Familie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aus sportlicher Sicht hat dieser Sonntag
eine Überraschung gebracht die
Schweizer
scheint in der ganzen Schweiz die Sonne
mit wenigen Schleierwolken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
konzentriert sind keine Umwelt macht
nicht
mit ihr neu orientiert sondern ihnen und
die ersten Bilder
[Musik]
sie hat eigentlich schon unter 30
Sekunden vielleicht 40 Sekunden noch
Start von dem Überfall wir 170
informieren und hat uns den geschildert
was jetzt da gerade Abgeordnete
[Musik]
Alarm immer noch
die Polizei durch sie
aber nur schneller sind
[Musik]
Kofferraum noch offen kann
keine Zimmer machen weil die Bilder des
großkriege
doch eh nur willst du viel Geld denn von
der Firma
ist eigentlich wie bei der Polizei
eine Chance hat nur als Team ja aber
wenn du der penalty
d
[Musik]
am Tatort selber dass ich wirklich
rechter nüchternd sehr wenig Spuren
gehabt
wo zurück klar wurde und bei der Heavys
[Musik]
ammlung
hier ist das erste deutsche Fernsehen
mit der Tagesschau in der Schweiz ist
ein spektakulärer Kunstraub verübt
worden einen Switzer
und dann hat sie angefangen
aufzählen was fällt und die Aufzählung
der Knabe mit der roten Weste von Pol
sesang
von Claude
und blühende kastanienzweige von Vincent
van Gogh Museums
[Musik]
genommen
wieso Überfall ich schalte sehr bekannt
dass sie der Regel so Fluchtfahrzeug
nicht wahnsinnig die erste
Fluchtfahrzeug nicht wahnsinnig wie
Fahrt schon die grundgesehen
und kontrolliert
[Musik]
das ist Resultat von der immer gleichen
Problematik dass man was entscheiden
zwischen Schutz vorm für und Schutz von
Diebstahl wollte sie gegen
diebstahlschützer den kann ich sie gar
nicht feststellen
die Sammlung gehört zu den wertvollsten
Privatsammlungen der Schweiz
Meisterwerke von Van Gogh über Picasso
bis zu Google hängen an den Wänden alles
Gemälde von unschätzbarem Wert
[Musik]
immer bringt sie so Maya bist du noch
nicht am Schlafen du musst mir nur
Gutenachtgeschichte vorlassen
der blaue Elefant im Orchester
[Musik]
und ich glaube er findet neue Lösung das
Konzert Ritter und wird das verzähl ich
dir morgen jetzt ist schlafen
[Musik]
drei Minuten brauchen die heute für
jeden Tag dann verließen sie das Museum
noch immer ist nicht bekannt ob eine
Videoüberwachung die Täter gefilmt hat
die Polizei gibt sich zugeknöpft das ist
eine taktische Überlegung die die
Polizei und das Museum für Damen und
getroffen haben wir möchten jetzigen
Zeitpunkt dazu keine Aussagen machen so
flüchteten die Täter in größten
kunstraumfall der Schweiz
[Musik]
viel bekannt dass du Sesam und vor dem
Van Gogh ist ja das große Stillleben 90
[Musik]
Belohnung hat das Museum ausgesetzt man
hofft mit Wisser finanziell damit zu
ködern betragen
die Konsequenzen grossen gesehen dass
sich da relativ viel Leute
vom more
das von Mexiko bis auf Dubai also die
ganz Bandbreite
betragen
am Nachmittag hat Polizei
auf dem Areal auf dem Parkplatz vor der
psychiatrische klinikburg hölzli ganz in
der Nähe Nummer wenige hundert Meter weg
von der sonnige Gebühren
Auto gefunden hat
[Musik]
auf dem Parkplatz gestanden und immer
hat die Bilder dem Auto in der
festgestellt ich möchte jetzt gar nicht
sieht das das hatten wir doch gesehen
und der Moment das ist eine Foto
sehr hoch gegangen
die lichterchecker mein Handy
überprüft dann müssen sie festgestellt
doch das Fahrzeugliste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Riese Apparate women und gesichert
vor dem Auto angeklungen
[Musik]
der internationalen Presse präsentiert
der Museumsdirektor die zurückgekehrten
Mode und van goghurtungen
[Musik]
Spuren gar und zwar
Delikt zusammen
bischof3 Überfall international tätig
man hat das Personen serbienen zuordnen
und die Person hat dies unfällt
organisierte Bande gehört von der
sogenannte Pink Panther die Person ist
sogenannte raumbock wo er Täterschaft
mittelsbachialqualität
[Musik]
die Delikt wo aus dem Phänomenbereich
verübt wurde sind die
ganzen speziellen Charakter man hat sich
sehr seriös und minutiös auf die Tat
vorbereitet mit Fluchtwagen abklärt man
hat Fahrzeug gestohlen und
bereitgestellt für den Tag X mehr hat da
in der Schweiz auch
bezirksnetze wo vom auskundschafter dann
letztendlich bis zum dort ausführende
verschiedenen
ganz bewusst
Waffen zurück zum Ziel sind
Personen sind Ausgang schon ein richtig
geworfen hätten aber relativ schnell
feststellt dass ich
Plastikspielzeug verhandelt sehr gut
noch gemacht es ist Spanisch Produkt
sehr schöne feststellen mit der mit dem
Aufschrift auf der Seite gestanden und
überlegen was dahinter steckt wieso das
möchte
strafrechtlich Relevanz
gespielt haben
im Raum auf deine Tasten
genau die richtig gegangen wo die Bilder
zieht das hat auch viel Aktionen
zu dem Zielpunkt
[Musik]
Informationen über den Standort vor der
Breite Bilder
[Musik]
die Person ist in Russland bei der
Polizei
behördenwerk kriminellen ist ob sich
wirklich in dem Umfeld bewegt
dass die Tätergruppierung die Bilder
verkaufen will und das wäre bezüglich
[Musik]
um halbe Million Euro
Überfall eigentlich Art
also auf einem Auto
das weiß man auch also ich glaube so
Bilder werde ich Stühle
flüssig machen
[Musik]
ob dein Moment
hat
[Musik]
identifiziert
entscheidend
[Musik]
einerseits
ist das Risiko das mit zweiter Bild
Weg ist aber zurück und deutlich größer
und einen guten Ansatzpunkt
[Musik]
Paul
Müller
der tumelt sich zwischen Belgrad und
Westeuropa aber
was genau
[Musik]
verwaltschaft und das ist sehr speziell
natürlich das muss
wieder Beschaffung
identifizieren und ich wollte die
Verantwortlichen
[Musik]
was sie für verstorben
Identitäten verdeckt die Ermittler soll
was für das Bild Gitter verdeckt
Ermittler was für eine Person ist damit
das Interesse weckt vor der Täterschaft
oder Verdächtigen dann wenn sie mit der
Polizei Rücksprache und sage ist die
Geschichte so gut hammerem
atisch
aber meine Verantwortung
den Platz
also es geht
zwei Bilder
halt
das
ist
ganz Europa
[Musik]
der verdeckte
gesetzt werden
organisiert die Kriminalität
[Musik]
ich muss es machen für ihn bitte
du verstehst wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
cool
insbesondere Fähigkeit in den anderen
Persönlichkeiten
sind
zwischen normalen und der effektive
Persönlichkeit
wie kommst du an die Frauen ran ich habe
eine gute Nase wenn es zum Girls geht
die bei den geilen Typen Punkten weißt
du und wie kommst du zu deiner guten
Nase ja lange Erfahrungen deine
Selbstversuche
natürlich
ich glaube ich hätte da was für Dich
müsstest du mal ausprobieren was zum
Beispiel ein Dreier vielleicht mit
goldenen Schauer
[Musik]
schwierig wird es erst wenn sie anfangen
mit zu reden du weißt schon diese ganze
Feministin Scheiße
gehört und vergiss nicht
spezifische Geschichte
ich bin Porno daheim
wie heißt der Frau wo auf dem Film seit
Erektion von der Darsteller
wie heißt der nachaufnahme vom Schwanz
wenn der Mann
[Musik]
das meint die Frau
Rebecca zu dem ganzen
Thema
ruhig reagieren
Kreditkarte
Handy
Taster sind eure Websites
ganze Persönlichkeit und konstruiert
wenn er seit ich bin aufgewachsen
dass man nicht checkt dass die
Geschichte nicht stimmt
[Musik]
oh mein Gott das reicht
nein
woher weißt du das ich weiß alles hier
aber das war Deutschland bist
und du
international tätig
und was machst du wenn du nicht die
Hausfrau spielst
also weißt du doch nicht alles ne
e
Autos
[Musik]
du gefällst mir
für uns
[Musik]
verhandelt hat der Kontakt hat
die verdeckte
und
risikobehaftet ist und sicher so vor
wirklich nur dann angewendet werden
[Musik]
aber alle findet er wird viel besser
Posaunen spielen mit dem Rüssel also
[Musik]
stumpft und jetzt sind alle würdig auf
ihn und er hat noch keine Löcher
gefunden
es Autohaus kommt dass der Kontakt
besteht bleibt
so interessiert Sie dass er sich selber
nach seiner Hoffnung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
etwas weich suchst du noch wie sagst du
denn Darsteller
[Musik]
gesagt
dein Boss das ist das für ein Typ Dieter
Deutscher hat eine Menge Kohle gemacht
Pornos mit Pornos und allem was dazu
gehört Drogen Frauen du weißt
wo macht ihr eure Filme überall in
Europa
und wie genau verdient ihr Geld
kostet es jede Minute und ihr geiler du
wirst desto mehr lässt du liegen oder so
nicht
ja
Dieter
Kontakt zu guten und wichtigen Leute
gemacht haben
ich glaube du solltest mal mitkommen
nach St Moritz würde dir bestimmt
gefallen
dann kann ich dir Dieter vorstellen wenn
du willst
bald werde ich auch reich sein
ich habe dein großes Ding am laufen
kann ich dir vertrauen
so gut kennen wir uns nicht
du könntest
du mich
[Musik]
könnt ihr euch interessieren
was will ich mit einem Bild die da
vielleicht
und woher weißt du dass es 100 Millionen
wert ist
Kind also wirklich im engere
Familienkreis als Freund aufgenommen
[Musik]
interessanter Charakter das hat offenbar
auch Polizei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich entschuldige mich noch mal für die
Verspätung das natürlich sehr unüblich
in der Schweiz
Verspätung
wenn man nicht natürlich sein
aber scheint gut zu laufen das ist ich
kann nicht klagen
Herr Brenner ihre Suite ist nun bereit
hier noch eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit des
Hauses dürfen wir sie zum Essen erwarten
natürlich
wie sieht es mit den Extras aus unser
Gast braucht dringend eine sanfte
Massage alles inszeniert noch mal
vorbereitet so dass der Bodensee hat
Demo der hat wirklich Geld das ist nicht
nur Blabla er hat mich wirklich geklaut
haben die schönsten Frauen auf der Welt
und ihr habt djokovic
hat
mal sehen
du bist unser Mann
ich habe noch etwas für dich
hier aus der Schweiz
geht ich muss mit dem
Kontakt halten ich muss sagen dass ich
mitnehmen
und das er dann Versicherung
aufgrund sein
ein Bild ein Bild
was soll ich mit einem Bild ein
Kunstwerk was soll ich mit einem
Kunstwerk
es ist der 100 Millionen Euro wert okay
und woher kommt es ein Museum hier in
der Schweiz gestohlen
und jetzt willst Du loswerden
bei mir zu Hause kommt es nicht richtig
zur geldung
ich bin leider kein Kunsthändler ich
mache Pornos
aber du kennst Leute Interesse haben
können an einem geklauten Bild
du meinst es könnte jemanden
interessieren dem es mal gehört hat
vielleicht
jemand der uns zurück haben will
überlegst dir
es ist dein
jetzt wollen wir uns erstmal ein
bisschen entspannen
und Spaß haben
danach haben wir genug Zeit für Kunst
haben
eigentlich der Durchbruch sie und von
wirklich ganz konkreten
nach St Moritz ist man dann dazu
eigentlich Interesse hat zum eigentlich
da der Deal abwickeln das heißt das ist
Angebot von vor
2,8 Millionen fürs Bild ist gemacht
worden
sich entschieden
der Staatsanwalt ist mit Bilder sofortig
nach kalt
zweifach wertvoller Bild gegangen aber
Auto ist innerhalb von der Stiftung und
der Stiftung
das ist grundsätzlich so dass sie für so
Ski Geld ist
gemäß gesetzt eigentlich
duftnationalparks und Nationalbank dann
das Geld hat zur Verfügung
was machst du da hey
[Musik]
wie lange noch
ich würde wenn das für mich den hummizug
und deprimiert zwei stinknormales leben
der macht die erste Richtung
[Musik]
natürlich niemand
scheiße
Mario
[Musik]
es ist klar
die Idee 1,4
zum das Geld in aller Ruhe irgendwo
parkieren sitzt das physische erkennt
Versteckens vor der Staatsanwalt von der
Polizei
gesagt okay mir Stiege doch da sie aber
Nummer war
das Bild aktuell
der Geburtstag von deiner Geliebten
nicht ganz
[Musik]
sind vom Lukas Gloor was Merkmal sind
dass er die verdeckter
entstanden
normal mit Ressourcen auch wieder
Verfahren investieren
wer hat gesagt das Geld stinkt ne ich
weiß wie das riecht
morgen will Dieter das Bild haben
aber was ist wenn dein Chef die Kohle
und dann
du glaubst ich leg Dich an ja
das kommt dann innerhalb von 24 Stunden
findet
einfach gemacht
der zuständige Staatsanwalt hat sicher
nicht sehr gut geschlafen er muss sich
aufgrund von ganze Bild von er vor Ort
hat halt überlegen und sagen ist es
jetzt halt
Bischof
hat dann natürlich das ganze Team hat
dann gespannt die Nerven und warte mal
was passiert jetzt oder
[Musik]
weißt du
das haben wir nicht so abgemacht
das wird Dieter nicht gefallen das sage
ich dir
du hörst von mir
[Musik]
genau zwei Stunden hört ihr euch
verarscht oder was
in Belgrad wir sind totalen
Polizisten
2 Millionen
es ist klar
oder nein
wirklich und ist zuverlässig traute
wirklich oder nicht
wichtig ist natürlich dass der
Staatsanwalt der Druck einfach aushalten
dass er Möglichkeiten
und und und und
[Musik]
und vielleicht mit einem Lüfter und dann
kommst Du mich besuchen oder klar 400000
schönes verstecken
du bist ein guter Vater
hier und das
Schweizer Qualität Achtung
[Musik]
ganz unten nur mit den Fingerspitzen
also Reproduktion ihre Reproduktion
anhebt
also Herr moderne Möse Hiwis gar wo
ihnen erlaube
sehe es hat gut ums Bild das ist reale
Bild
und da hat ihr Biss Kind Detail kennt
das Bild wie alle unsere Bilder wo man
sie systematisch Händler fotografieren
abgenommen
hier sind die 400.000 den Rest gibt es
im Hotel wie vereinbart
wie war das noch mal bei diesem
juwelierbefall seitdem erwischt wurde
was meinst du du hast ja gesagt du hast
mal auf jemanden
wahrscheinlich ist er tot warum fragst
du
ich überlege und
ich weiß nicht ich
und riesige genau halten er hat nur
unbegrenzte Spielraum er muss das machen
was im Plan
vorgesehene Sicherheit gewährleistet ist
damit Schutzkonzepte
ich bin ein guter Vater
und dragani einem Puzzle
ich dachte du hast keine Kinder
ich ja
meine Eltern haben mir das immer
vorgelesen deine Eltern
dieses Kinderbuch
gibt es noch nicht so lange ja
stimmt
dass wir
das Sanierung
[Musik]
vorsichtig sie die ganze Zeit die sind
immer davor Ausgaben
extrem vorsichtig und letztendlich auch
vom Boden
und transportiert wird zum Hotelzimmer
oder zweite verdeckte Worte mit dem
restlichen Geldeinheiten
[Musik]
kein Mensch wenn er das Bild schneller
haben will soll er die restliche Kohle
herbringen
wir sind jetzt in einer Garage kein
Scheiß Standort
[Musik]
er bleibt noch
alles in Ordnung du bist blass alles gut
vorhin
ich dachte das wären die Bullen
die Bullen
ich dachte du hättest mich verpfiffen
wie kommst du jetzt da drauf so ein
Gefühl in mein neuer
[Musik]
das mit den Eiern überlässt du schön mir
mein Business
[Musik]
Position
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ist wirklich jetzt kommt 100%ig
und nach Belgrad geflogen
am Flughafen und so vip-mäßig durch
Stadtzentrum von belgradfahrer Garage
[Musik]
das ist jetzt das ist es also wirklich
und ich bin
ob das jetzt tatsächlich unser Bild ist
[Musik]
und
100% Saison
[Musik]
Festnahmen von der Räuber was
größermaßen dazu führt dass es sich aber
vielleicht eher nicht wird wiederholen
also die abschrecken die wichtig wo so
bis jetzt ist nicht unterschätzen das
ist für das Staatsanwalt natürlich
mindestens so wichtig wir druckfähig vom
Bild man darf nicht vergessen
Organisation für Logistik verantwortlich
sind wenn man den Tätergruppen erlaubt
sich da nieder dann werden sie das auch
weiblich ausnutzen und es wird natürlich
im Kanton Zürich deutlich unsicher
das ist ein großer Erfolg
auf internationaler Ebene
nach vier Jahren intensiver
internationaler polizeiliche Arbeit sind
die beiden letzten gestohlenen Werke
wieder zurück
es war uns klar dass uns nur eine Chance
bleibt ein Fehler ein falscher Schritt
und das Vertrauen der Täter ja die ganze
Operation würde Gefahren Laufen zu
scheitern
alles entscheidende Faktor und das ist
vielleicht Fazit
ist die verdeckte unumstritten
[Musik]
und man hat eine
mögliche Spuren für wusstet aus
die Person löst sich in Luft auf
verschwindet spurlos da gibt es hat mir
existiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Junge mit dem wunderschönen roten
Seele
das ist eben nicht nur ein Meilenstein
für die international bedeutendes
für die gesamte Kunstgeschichte und
ihrem fing das alles großes Glück dass
mir das Bild jetzt gemeinsam können
[Musik]